of an angle let's just call that angle
theta if this arc length okay so the
length of that curve segment is the same
length as the radius so we'll just call
this R and s if this arc length is the
same length of that radius this angle
here is called 1 or 8 in 1 R a dia n
sometimes abbreviated as 1 r ad 1 Radian
so you can see here if you were to
rotate all the way to here 180 degrees
that's going to be 1 2 3 and a little
bit more so this is PI which is 3.14
radians okay so pi radians which is the
same thing as 180 degrees this is 3.14
rating so a Radian is about it's
approximately we can think of it as 57
degrees approximately but the way that
we convert from radians to degrees is we
actually use this conversion factor that
pi radians is the same thing as 180
degrees so we can use a conversion
factor PI over 180 for 180 degrees over
pi ok so let's take a look at some
examples so like say for example you
wanted to convert from 45 degrees to
radians so what we can do is 45 degrees
we're starting with which is like 45
degrees over 1 anything divided by 1 is
itself we're gonna multiply it by PI
radians over 180 degrees now you know
you have it correctly because the
degrees that unit it's going to cancel
numerator and denominator when we
multiply across we're gonna be left with
radians
so if we multiply the numerators we get
45 PI we multiply the denominator
we get 180 and then we can reduce 45
goes in here once 45 goes in here four
times so this equals PI over four
radians okay let's do another example
say you have let's just do a hundred
degrees so a hundred degrees again
there's PI radians for every 180 degrees
the degree units cancel you multiply the
numerators and denominators and reduce
so this will give you an exact Radian
measure so we have 100 PI over 180 you
can reduce by dividing by 10 you can
reduce again dividing by 2 so you get 5
PI over 9 radians okay now let's do some
examples where you're converting from
radians back to degrees so say for
example you have 2 PI over 9 radians so
let's start over here 2 PI over 9 2 PI
over 9 radians so now what we're going
to do is we're going to multiply by PI
and 180 so 180 over PI these are
equivalent so it's like multiplying by
one this doesn't change the value of
this angle it's just changing the units
from radians to degrees so notice the PI
radians cancel out you can multiply
across numerator and denominator you get
360 divided by 9 this is in degrees and
if you reduce further you get 40 degrees
okay so we just converted from 2 PI over
9 to 40 degrees these are equivalent
angles it's just that this one's in
radians that was in degrees we'll do one
more example let's say we have a 5 PI
over 4
okay want to convert that one to degrees
now just another note if you don't see a
degree symbol that little circle right
here then you know that it's in radians
so if somebody just writes 3 is
three degrees it's actually three
radiancy because it doesn't have the
degree symbol so if it doesn't have that
symbol you know it's in radians a lot of
times you'll see these pi when you see a
Radian measure angle measure but it
doesn't have to have that pi it could
just be three in that store radians so
let's go ahead and multiply this one by
180 degrees for every pi radians you can
see the PI's are gonna cancel four goes
in here once
four goes in here 45 if I multiply
across I'm just pre reducing numerator
and denominator okay top and bottom and
when you multiply across you get 225
degrees and that's your answer okay so
this has been about converting radians
to degrees degrees to radians and a
little bit about what a Radian is I'll
see in the next video